the first word that comes to mind is
vulnerability so I feel like it works if
you are a vulnerable leader where you
admit your mistakes I wouldn't tell them
to anything I wouldn't do I wouldn't not
jump on any call and any email go to any
meeting and you bring yourself down to
their level because everyone makes
mistakes like I lost a retainer pitch
this week telling them why I think I
didn't win it and giving them the
feedback the client gave me that
vulnerability I just think is so
important I hate saying my team like
into the team it's not my team I don't
own anybody I don't own anything you
don't create this hierarchy that doesn't
need to be there